high-ranking officials from FIFA the
sport's governing body arrested in an
overnight raid in Switzerland I thank
you that you accepted me for the next
four years
please make Sepp Blatter go away he
needs a new president
Swiss police crustmas annual meeting in
Zurich and arrested 14 people on charges
stemming from a 3-year FBI investigation
into the international soccer I mean
football organization going to jail
somebody's going to jail I'm gonna East
Fairweather and how did they investigate
what were the charges and what does this
mean for my future husband on Spain's
2014 World Cup team because I will marry
all of them this is hashtag news let's
figure this out for those of you who
don't know FIFA is the multi-billion
dollar organization at internationally
governed soccer the most popular sport
in the world and also home to the most
attractive men anyone has ever seen yeah
that's right ladies get into soccer but
here in America all we know is that
soccer is like the game that
twelve-year-old girls play does that
look like a twelve-year-old girl no even
though the United States isn't that
interested in soccer they aren't
interested in bringing FIFA to trial for
I don't know a little bribery and
corruption for the past 20 years but I
mean who hasn't dabbled in a little
international corruption just me awesome
what were they being bribed to do
basically they let the money decide who
would televise games where the games
would be held and who would run the
organization overseeing organized soccer
worldwide stay with me this is gonna be
a hefty a 47 count indictment names nine
FIFA officials in five sports executives
involved in an alleged 24-years scheme
involving more than a hundred and fifty
million dollars which investigators say
turned the sport into a criminal
enterprise oh yes listen I did grow up
in United States so I'm not a huge
soccer fan
besides David Beckham's midsection torso
but like a good American I am a huge fan
of Internet
the Twittersphere has exploded over this
mostly an overwhelming joy and
vindication not only from soccer fans
but even from former players like Gary
Lineker
who called FIFA the most corrupt
deplorable organization on earth so why
is America the country who changed the
name to soccer the one who is bringing
down the hammer on FIFA the United
States government has actually been
keeping an eye on them for a while why
you asked when FIFA awarded the 2018
World Cup to Russia and then followed
that decision by awarding a more head
scratching choice of Qatar other
governments called shenanigans the
United States they wanted to make sure
that no wrongdoing had taken place on US
soil the US government sent out Michael
Garcia former US attorney to find out
what was going on
so Michael Garcia spent 19 months
investigating and put together a three
hundred and 50 page report thiefbug bend
it down to 42 pages and clear themselves
of any wrongdoing he's unbelievable just
unbelievable Garcia called FIFA's
findings on his report incomplete and
erroneous subscribe so that we can find
out together if fateful officials are
going to be found guilty when they're
extradited into the United States to
face trial what do I think about this
with 100 million dollars I could buy
like five Ronaldo but I only want one
like a tiny Ronaldo this tiny little
finger sized leg
I was kicking yeah I mean they would be
tiny that they would be strong I'm a
nice fair weather and I need to know if
you think Ronaldo is hot let me know in
the comments like this video because you
are sincere and all those face a few
times oh also yet corruption is bad and
soccer is kind of interesting right I'm
gonna go learn more Spanish so I will be
to embera Tsavo when I pluck Berlin
although I Portuguese
it's pregnant this ten by my statement
I'm gonna be embarazada